حسنًا ، أخبرك أنني علمت بذلك وعرفت
مرة أخرى من الاتجاه العام
رياضة ريال مدريد دعنا نقول
الفائدة التي يجب أن تخرج من
القديسين
لكنني لم أكن أعرف جيدًا ، إلى جانب ذلك ، لا أحد غيره
قل لي في العام 2011
كان ريال مدريد على استعداد للدفع
شرط جرح سانتوس ل
خذ اللاعب
حسنًا ، لا أعرف ما هو البند
2011 في الملخص في مدريد
قدمت الإدارة الرياضية عرضًا
من قبل اللاعب إلى سانتوس
يعرف كم
حسنًا ، يظهر في الملخص بعد 45
مليون لأنني انتهيت للتو
اسم المستخدم
ماذا حدث إذن لماذا لا اللاعب
ذهب إلى ريال مدريد
حسنا اللاعبين الذين يذهبون إلى أين
لديهم في هذه الحالة أعتقد أن
نيمار أراد الذهاب إلى برشلونة وهذا هو السبب
ذهبت إلى برشلونة
حسنًا ، جاء ريال مدريد لصنع
عرض 60 مليون في 2011 ل
الاستيلاء على اللاعب
أعتقد أنه في عام 2011 كان 45
مليون أو نحو ذلك هو العرض الوحيد
هو ما يتم تسجيله في الملفات
من ريال مدريد